yeah I know what welcome to this video
playing I am draw me down was that again
just the whole so the wrong korea tech
no switches back into a regular clothes
Sicilian now there are many decent
setups there I always had a soft spot
for those b6 setups in fact that plate
this kind of setup with white quite a
bit edgy for your almost always going to
answer this even though it six looks
pretty weak now yeah well normally you
always take with the Jeep on but here I
don't feel that this looks good what is
he doing here wouldn't be for hanging
why can I not take a g4 I will okay I
can't even just secular exchange him
wouldn't be wouldn't be such a bad idea
I can definitely definitely play that
and Confirmation looks pretty good the
only thing that annoys me is he has 95
now okay 93 this is probably getting the
exchange bag I don't think you can allow
me to take 1 G 2 it would be surprising
with the bishop coming to be seven ok
[Music]
why can you play that isn't night before
good and goopy 7 or what's the deal yeah
okay seven sure
okay i want to take and play Queen f5
and he takes them okay so Queen and five
immediately
i get i get to spawn back on the five at
least and I mean this is almost medium
so it's not at all easy yeah Brooke
cheeks is checking me I wonder if I just
should to take with the pawn
I mean he cannot the largest 1985 he
probably has to move the chemo or
something in the area now I can take
down okay hmm so grab more stuff oh sure
if I should okay
this Bishop even check nature as an idea
mean things i want to have a person now
i have a couple of yeah it should be one
if I get this porn so that my bishop
covers f5 and then the whole position is
excellently coordinated okay
okay yeah I don't want to go back
somehow that looks but then I'm just in
this chick yeah I'm in checks anyway hey
not much that I can do ok so here I can
check then check here check on d5
doesn't do all that much I can only five
though just keep everything I think the
teacher that you wrong with it I think
okay
ok
time learning no no I just blundered
this in one who flower so there is a way
to lose this game hahaha i find it
unbelievable i know not soon after this
kind of game I mean that's it that's
really really really wrong I mean there
was such a one-sided game I might do in
actually the pawns are pretty strong
maybe maybe I can actually just come up
a dead bishop is extremely useless I
might still be winning even though I
totally blundered a two in one move
I am yeah I think its feelings cause I
just too strong 1480 time jump yeah I
don't know it was a bit but I see the
whole game from start to finish but yeah
I just don't believe in G for that that
early maybe maybe he had somewhat
interesting because the bishop is on a
six but it's tough to believe yeah okay
it can also go d 4 which is more solid
but but I thought that this is
interesting after after this I should
have enough compensation and then gives
equal yeah I've got a good porn here and
his pawn structure is bad so it should
be fine but maybe play many moves now
check instantly almost there he has to
give it back the debt that just pretty
terrible about the taking on z3 is a lot
stronger not even allow 95 I was to
round 2 tempted to have the two bishops
here I mean this is yeah that's also
good for me but maybe Bishop takes as
you see 3 was stronger like a statistic
player for the exchange oh I can take d
3 yeah I didn't
did you see that I just saw that this is
king extremely comfortable okay I think
she's I don't even with all that bad
what I did until i blundered a to the
show okay so yeah I mean just be three
first and then see why I'm just I'm just
pushing this home they just promote I
just had a complete brain slept there
currently the computers has 007 with
whatever that means licensed to kill you
wsm it tasted raw computer finds a drone
yet it will be to a now its ruling what
King no still not losing how is he going
well now it's not drawing okay so Bishop
age four drawers hmm why why is that not
waiting for me I because it is this move
c3 should be shipped and now i can check
this and this is the draw okay okay so
he has to quickly go there too to be
able to second interesting and now it
was lost now i just be three aces it's
just behem just the other movement I'm
pushing this homo c4 was that your
blundering this ok guys thanks for
watching